Welcome, everybody.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You are here.
Thank you for watching.
I'm very excited about this.
Rosie O'Donnell is
on the show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Suga is here!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
It's a big night.
It's a big night for us
because we've done close to 100
shows this year
and they've all been Suga-free.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you guys,
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie"
is number one
at the box office right now.
And we thought with Suga
here tonight,
we combine music
from the biggest movie
with dancing
from the biggest pop star.
Let's see what happens.
[ "Super Mario Bros. Hurry Up"
plays ]
♪♪
[ Coin dings ]
-Yeah, that's the way to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
That's the way to do it.
Oh, there's a buzz
in the building today.
There's a buzz in the building.
Well, there's a lot going on
in New York City.
I mean, earlier tonight
was the 2023 Met Gala.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was honored to be there.
Although picking an outfit
can be very stressful.
I mean, you spend
all weekend
wondering which chandelier
can I turn into a hat?
You know? It was a fun night,
but it was hard to top last year
when I apparently showed up
as Kendall Jenner's
ventriloquist dummy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tonight, the Met Gala honored
fashion designer Karl Lagerfeld.
Here's a classic photo of Karl.
Yeah, he was basically President
Biden from the year 2099.
[ Laughter ]
The future.
Well, speaking of Biden,
on Saturday night,
he gave some remarks
at the White House
Correspondents' Dinner.
Yep, Biden made jokes
about his age, Ron DeSantis,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Fox News.
Afterwards, he called me up
and said,
"Jimmy, I got to say,
your job's not that hard."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this. I read
that the U.S. military
has been tracking
a mysterious balloon
that just flew over Hawaii.
Is it me or does
"mystery balloon over Hawaii"
sound like a breakfast
special at Denny's?
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Spirit Airlines
had to explain themselves
after a viral video
showed a maintenance worker
making a quick repair
before takeoff.
This is real.
Look at this.
-Some Spirit Airlines passengers
were pretty
shaken up when they saw
a mechanic
taping a portion of their wing
together on their plane.
One passenger
posted this video.
You can see him
sticking the tape there.
This tape is called speed tape.
It's an aluminum-based
pressure-sensitive tape
that can withstand high winds
and temperatures.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
If you're wondering
what the difference
between speed tape
and duct tape is,
speed tape is made-up.
[ Laughter ]
That's duct tape.
Airplanes do use tape.
For instance, today,
Southwest taped one of
its planes to a Delta flight
so it could actually take off.
[ Laughter ]
Duct taped the wing?
No! Speed tape.
Oh, my gosh.
Guys, I saw that
an iceberg in Canada
is getting a lot of attention
thanks to its unique shape.
Take a look.
See if you see anything on it.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Scientists said, "Well, that's
just the tip of the iceberg."
-Oh!
-There's more.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Wow. A lot of blue on that one.
-Even the Titanic was like,
"I'd hit that."
[ Laughter ]